i feel like i'm making things worse i'm
pretty worried how it's going to turn
out my hands are shaking
hi guys it's really so i started
watching great british baking show
this season's first episode they had
this outrageous challenge
they had to make 3d cake of one of their
hero
it was very funny episode but if you
are competitor i think this is very
difficult challenge
i want to do same challenge with the
same rules
a must have a head it has to be made out
of cake
you have to complete cakes within four
hours
today i'm going to make 3d cake of
my friend mickey
[Laughter]
really you told me it was adam
it's you i'm good i just wanna
suppress you making your cake
i'm going to start baking nicky's head
and body
making cake batter is not difficult but
it has to be in the oven about 45
minutes
but i want to take more time for carving
and decorating the cake so
i want to move fast i prefer using a
standard mixer and i'm going to just
like whisk
so what you're looking for is kind of
pale yellow color
when you use baking soda you want to use
some acidity so butter
milk that's the job so i'm baking olive
oil cake
because it's less cranberry like butter
based cake
so i thought it would be great cake to
stack everything
up together i want to make sure to use
nice good quality olive oil because i'm
using three cup it's a lot
while stone mix is mixing my butter
i'm going to line my cake pan
and i'm thinking what can i make like
round shape i'm going to bake cake
butter
in a bowl and once it's baked i'm going
to
put two together hope this works i don't
know
how much i should i want to make sure
even way the most recent season like i
enjoy a lot but they did japanese
week and i must mention that it wasn't
great so if they are looking for
a japanese consultant just call me
i'll be there i order almost even amount
of cake butter in a 8 inch cake pan
and a two metal bowl and top to remove
the
air bubble i'm going to bake this cake
about 35 minutes to 45 minutes and the
first part is done
i'm going to spread jam in between the
cake
and i'm making raspberry jam for the
filling and i want to make sure this
cake
is delicious as well in the show judge
is always tasting the cake
and if it doesn't taste good you could
go home
and usually i macerated for 30 minutes
i don't want to run out of the time so
i'm gonna just skip that
do you remember when we watched the
episode
i asked you what would you make as a 3d
cake
who is your hero do you remember who you
said i said spongebob squarepants
spongebob is not real
i'm basically making four different
components
and you have to use time right you have
to be very smart about it
making jump takes a little bit time so
i'm going to cook this on the side
and move on to my next step i'm going to
make swiss meringue buttercream
and that's nikki's favorite thing
i like road flavor a lot but in the show
it's kind of tricky ingredients if it's
too much
the judge doesn't like it but it's too
little they also don't like it
so swiss meringue you are making
meringue
warmed up in a hot water bath
and you want to melt sugar completely
it's nice there is no judge i'm
like less pressured right now so
temperature is good
and it's kind of look flossy and whisk
egg whites
until stiff peak while i'm waiting
meringue is
whipping i'm going to cut my butter
okay i think the meringue is
good nice stiff peak i'm going to add
butter and my butter cream is done
when i taste it it looks so good
so my buttercream is delicious i think
my all components ready i have less than
90 minutes left
and i've made buttercream before cake
before jam before
so next actual challenge begins
time to assemble so i want it to make it
a little bit rounder but it's a little
bit flat
but you know i think we can make it
happen
so i don't need to cut this cake because
it's pretty
flat but i want to use
cake crumb so nikki have round head like
using ice cream scooper
[Music]
i'm gonna create kind of tube jam it's
nice and gelatinous
this part is going to be nikki's body
kind of have a like blood
so i was going to use this cake stand
because this is what the some of the
contestants used but i'm gonna
not use it so i'm going to put
so it doesn't move
[Music]
and i'm going to put the round
top it's going to be nikki's shoulder
this is not going to be
presented like this i'm going to use
fondant so
it doesn't need to be too pretty have
you made anything
anywhere close to something like this oh
i made a bunny cake there's a scary
bunny
you go to mall one take a picture i
didn't understand the concept so i made
a three
eye bunny all right i think this looks
good
now it's ahead time it's kind of look
like bb-8
the same thing i think i should have cut
this part
straight but it's too late now or is it
too late
it's not too late it's like free
freestyle
there's a lot of moments like this on
the show
i wanted to make this straight and put
it here so i thought it wasn't too late
but
my bottom of the cake is peeled off but
it's okay
you're laughing but do you think you can
make this
it's actually worked you have neck now
nikki's neck is a little bit wobbly you
have to stack
layer of cake so it's easy to slide down
so i'm using stick one of my favorite
part about
that episode someone's head fall off and
they have to use like
neck pillow and i hope it doesn't happen
to me
and this is mickey's yeah like face
brain okay so i'm going to stick
this
yes okay so i'm going to
fill the gap it's a little bit tilted
isn't it right now
nikki has flathead i'm going to
crumble this cake with frosting like a
cake pop
at this point i'm just like winging it
because i still have to
make a fondant and paint her face and
stuff
try not to make it like a cone head i
feel like it's a little bit
pointy head now but it's okay
i was very confident about baking cake
part
i'm gonna just do my best well the good
thing is like i have nobody to compete
with
and i'm going home anyways look at this
exactly okay so this is gonna be nikki's
face paint i always do this i
don't know what they are doing but
annie draw nikki from eating a feed
crepe cake episode so i'm going to use
this as a reference
a lot of competitors was making
realistic version of their hero
but if i make animated version i think i
can execute it better
i'm going to start covering this cake
with fondant
i only worked with fondant one time
so i'm pretty worried how it's gonna
turn out
well i don't like the smell at all
oh my god nikki is wearing brown sugar
i'm going to
try to make brown color i had no idea
what
food gel color combination become brown
and pink it is becoming very stressful
it just doesn't look like any color it's
like dirty
play-doh i wanted to make nikki's shirt
but it kind of looked like nikki's skin
tone
so i'm gonna just use this as a her face
it's like cleaning chewing gum from like
back with a chair or something
it's kind of creepy too i thought it's
gonna be
easy but i'm running out of time for
decoration so i'm gonna
keep kneading as fast as i can
i still have to make hair too hard i
should
walk fast this is my workout for the day
it's just getting dirtier dirtier can i
just make a black shirt
i want it to make brown but you see it's
just like
weird marble but i have to move on so
i'm gonna just
pretend this is harsher i still have to
make like
black for her hair eyebrow and i i'm
getting hot
i didn't like eating fondant cake and
now i hate making food pancake
so now i have pink color black
and white and i'm going to start with
her shirt
you want to roll as thin as possible
and i'm going to make a slit
[Music]
yes oh it's actually worked a little bit
sliding
but well it's not perfect but i
shall move on i'm not sure if i can make
it
in a time nikki might be a like bald
lady
i just have to make sure face it's
covered in this way
stick coming out i think i can come up
with
hair i'm going to make face first
and use left over for all the hair
bakers you have 10 minutes remaining
oh my god i get panicked all the time i
just don't show
should i do hair first maybe so this is
all
i have left
okay making an executive decision
because i don't have time
oh i'm so sad you look like a nun
okay so i'm gonna use this as a
oh my glue are shaking
it's a big bald spot how can i make it
look like you now
wait i think if i put here okay so let
me make ya really quick
i feel like i'm making things worse i'm
gonna just like
make a wave i think i should have done
that but
there is no going back
10 seconds remaining
[Music]
bakers your time is up stop stop stop
time's up
i feel like my carrier is over
nikki
i didn't see the buck first
how do you feel like you did
like i usually take a photo with my you
know cakes and like
do instagram posts
i don't but i don't i don't know it is a
head
and it's cake and you did it in four
hours
i'm a chef i'm not the artist rye is
like one of the best
bakers that i know and the fact that
this was like hard for her
probably means this challenge was like
very difficult it's like also like head
sized right oh
man now i feel like we should make
everyone do this
time go so fast when you are making
so many different components also like i
was making by myself but
actual competition is more pressured
positive side it doesn't look like nikki
but
the taste would be great i had a great
time i learned a lot so
maybe next time i can make better
[Music]